hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
uh monday july 12 2021
what is going on how are you
how was your weekend other than england
how was your weekend everybody how'd you
have a good time and say
whoa italy
whoa whoa whoa whoa i watched
that [ __ ] gay hey
um jesus [ __ ] christ i think i
finally get it
i think i finally [ __ ] get it you
watch soccer
right what happened was right every time
i talk about soccer whatever they always
have to bring up like american football
they're two completely different [ __ ]
games
and then they always i don't know it's
like well i don't understand why those
[ __ ] are just
always [ __ ] on american football you
don't have to watch it
[Music]
you [ __ ] on american football so then i
[ __ ] on soccer and then you act like
like
like i [ __ ] started it um
i don't know maybe i did but anyways i
was live tweeting the game and i
they just take the bait every [ __ ]
time like they think i really don't like
the sport i don't give a [ __ ]
right and i don't give a [ __ ] i [ __ ]
enjoy it
i see it i get it people are going crazy
i know the whole world [ __ ] loves it
so yeah there's got to be something to
it i just don't have the time to watch
it
other than that you know i mean what the
[ __ ] i'm saying at this point i watch
the [ __ ] game and i have to tell you
something matt
that is the worst i have felt after a
sporting event
since i saw kenny perry who i love
go from winning the masters to then
losing the masters
in in whatever you call it over time in
golf whatever that's called
a playoff you know not to [ __ ] dig up
an old wound
but this [ __ ] guy was crushing it i
watched i just sat down one year and
the year i decided to watch the whole
masters thursday
friday and sunday
i'm watching this guy he never won one
he's up there in age
you see this is his year you know he's
built like a dad he's got a family
the guys don't like the 14th 15th
[ __ ] hole he's got it in the bag
they're cutting to his family sitting on
the 18th hole they're all excited holy
[ __ ] that's gonna do it
he's gonna do it ma he's really gonna do
it and all of a sudden the wheels fall
off
and they start cutting back to the
family and the the smiles
are now going to like concern
and then it just went totally off the
rails by the time he got to the 18
and it was tied i think nobody was
looking at anybody
and then he walked off to go to the
[ __ ] playoff
playoff and uh they never showed his
family again
and then he lost
he blew it in front of his whole family
it's basically what happened
and uh and then lost to a guy named
bubba
who took the money and went out and
bought a 69 dodge
challenger i believe that was made up to
look like the dukes of hazard car so i
mean it was just
i remember him telling the story he said
he walked into the clubhouse
signed off on his score
didn't talk to his family got in his car
and just started driving
i can't imagine what was going through
his family's head like he he wouldn't
hurt himself would he i mean and we
to just like people shouldn't go through
that
so i'm watching this this uh
soccer right i sit down to watch it it's
the championship so you know
fair fairweather fan i can sit down i
can wash this for all the [ __ ]
marbles
and i sit down and i'm like oh [ __ ] it's
england versus italy
i got some english blood in me irish
scottish i got that old [ __ ] thing
going on there i got a little french
mostly german okay
i got a buddy of mine named paul verzie
paul versey
whoa paul versey
sicily and sicilian
it's like all right man let's get into
this [ __ ] let's go you want to do 20
bucks in the game i'll take the pasty
guys you take the olive skin guys
and he's like make it 50.
because he's version it's like all right
i'm making [ __ ] 50.
so we sit down to watch the game i'm
texting him he's not texting me back i
didn't think you know
i didn't think he was even watching or i
know what the [ __ ] he was doing oh
golfing or something so i started
jumping on the twitter there and i i
suddenly realized how big this [ __ ]
thing was
i made some stupid joke when i saw uh
the blonde guy there the older brother
the favorite son
the guy who's gonna be king someday if
he can put poison in the right chalice
in that [ __ ]
castle right um
he's there with his wife and his his kid
who already looks like he has the weight
of the world
on his shoulders there's something about
that suit like this this kid's already
seen things
it's crazy um you know somebody there
must have left their laptop open or
something he walked into the wrong room
in the castle
um but anyway uh
all i could think it was was harry i was
relating to harry right
outcast ginger you know
[ __ ] moved away from his sports
place and all of a sudden they're gonna
win a championship that's what happened
to me i left boston
and uh well it didn't happen right away
i
left boston and then i went through the
whole [ __ ] yankee dynasty 99 i was
choking
aaron boone i went through a whole bunch
of [ __ ] uh but the pats
pats came alive like six years after i
left
um and i was just thinking like he must
have been sitting there like ah [ __ ]
i could have been at the game or the
match whatever the [ __ ] they call it
so i made a joke about that and then my
whole twitter feed just like lights up
all these [ __ ] lunatic
fanatic [ __ ] fans you don't [ __ ]
believe how crazy these fans are
dude they showed a clip of some fans
italian supporters coming into wembley
stadium
and these [ __ ] old bald english [ __ ]
like my age
they look they think they 40s and 50s
were just
beating the [ __ ] out of them two on one
four on one and there was just this
right i couldn't tell what was going on
it's this rush of italian people dressed
with italian colors on it looked like
you know when the wildebeest tried to
cross the river at the wrong time
during the serengeti dry season and the
alligators are just picking them off it
was just [ __ ]
sucker punch after [ __ ] sucker punch
deplorable
deplorable human behavior um
which i got to admit i uh selfishly i
loved
humanitarianly you know human being to
human being i hated seeing it
but selfishly i loved it because those
english [ __ ] always try to act like
they're a little cut above
you know what i mean try to act like
there's not a sea of dumb [ __ ]
in jolly old england just like there is
over here
you know we're just a little more
obvious because one company turned our
food supply into poison and now we're
all bloated up
like a bunch of [ __ ] i don't know
what weather balloons over here
so like you look twice as dumb if you're
dumb and
fat you know what i mean if you just
dumb you know what i mean
you can you can kind of get like the
south of god bless his heart you know
they'll
give you a little bit of that really
means go [ __ ] yourself you know that
guy's an idiot or whatever whatever that
southern thing works but like
you know if you're dumb and fat in the
south you don't get you don't get bless
his heart
i'll tell you right now he looks like he
ate the baby jesus and the manger [ __ ]
that
dumb fat [ __ ] i'll run over with my
truck i'll keep going
chop them up put them in my bass boat
use them for bait watch me
says one more [ __ ] thing to me when
i'm walking down to that goddamn gun
shop
um
anyway so i sit down to watch this
[ __ ]
match so i got 50 bucks riding on
england i immediately regret it
because you know irish people giving me
[ __ ] i thought you know i
thought you were [ __ ] irish or
whatever and i'm like i'm you know i'm
mostly
[ __ ] american
i thought that [ __ ] english flag i'm
like why what the [ __ ] did
did sweden lose and they're just hanging
around
are they playing the [ __ ] the the
runner-up game after this game i don't
even know i didn't even know what the
[ __ ] english flag i thought was that
that up that one that def leppard had
that they made into little boy shorts
right
who's that rick allen the drummer he
came over wearing those [ __ ] things
right
we all thought it was cool we thought it
meant rock or whatever rock and roll
whatever but i just thought i thought
that was england's flag
and i guess also i didn't really notice
this when they go to the [ __ ]
olympics
when they go to the olympics they they
bring the great britain flag
which is i guess northern ireland
scotland wales and them
isle of man i don't know what the [ __ ]
it is over there who gives a [ __ ] right
whatever everybody
you do you guys know where [ __ ]
nebraska is
um did you just compare our country to
nebraska
yes i'm on the other side of it as far
as i don't know where the [ __ ] it is
um or how do how it's all aligned
so anyway
they they they're under the different
flag but whatever i can see i see the
pasty [ __ ] i'm like all right that's
england now i got my money on that horse
and then uh you know versions got it on
the uh the italian
team all right which really killed me
to root against italy
because the mediterranean people they
all they basically by going over there
i really figured it out as far as like
you know there's something about the
mediterranean sea people chill
like they they know how to live they get
it
you know food is an event you take a nap
in the afternoon
you know it's about those mo it's not
about [ __ ] you know you get up north
it starts getting colder all of a sudden
people
they got to feel superior and [ __ ]
try to take people over
well this is [ __ ] because france and
italy also had empires so did
greek i don't know it's just this
at this moment in history i'll tell you
what
every country's had their crazy people
but as far as just regular
people walking around chilling they
chill out pretty good
you can have a good time then again
isn't italy overrun by the mafia
all right this whole theory is [ __ ]
unwinded whatever
whatever
i have a good time when i'm down by the
mediterranean okay i'm [ __ ] sorry
anyway
so plus you know i got a lot of italian
friends over here
times you know how to cook they know how
to hug you know they're warm people
before they put
two behind your beer right it's supposed
to irish it's just you know throw it in
the [ __ ] pot you know the germans
they did it you know
once are you part of the solution your
positive problem you know that very
[ __ ]
cold goddamn people so
i'm rooting for england i got my money
on england right
the game starts england goes down the
ice right they cross the blue line
the [ __ ] guy is along the boards he
kicks it across
a little one-timer right [ __ ] right
there fred
it's basically what soccer is right it's
[ __ ] you know talky on grass
just way more players and a giant goal
so they score
and i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it's one
to nothing
already they got 90 more minutes to
score one more goal and this whole
[ __ ] thing is over
and then what happened was
like an hour of nothing it was a lot of
sing-alongs
with some complaining there was some
rolling around on the ground
people putting their scarves over their
heads
and i'm like how is the whole world what
the [ __ ] am i missing
and then because i had money on the game
and because i gave a [ __ ]
all of a sudden i was feeling this
nervousness
or i was going you know nobody's scored
in a while
i mean if i know one thing about
watching sports if you let them hang
around
you let them hang around you know
you got to put them to bed you got to
put them to bed early
you knock them out you stick them in the
bunk you tuck them in and you shut out
the [ __ ] light and if you don't
if you just slap them across the face
and once that sting wears off and their
cheeks a little hot and red
they start getting mad they're getting
mad right
all of a sudden the tide of the game
changes
because i'm sitting there watching
england i'm like are they playing
[ __ ] mardi ball
they're gonna sit on the [ __ ] lead
let's get aggressive let's get down to
goddamn [ __ ] whatever you call it
the rosary be the pitch
so anyway i go outside
i don't go outside go to the end of the
kitchen making myself a little pizza
and all of a sudden i hear the first
something that i haven't heard in about
an hour i heard the sound of excitement
and i was like holy [ __ ] did england
just somebody just scored
it has not been this [ __ ] loud in
well over an hour and i
ran in and i see the guys in the blue
shirts
they're [ __ ] going nuts
and then i was i don't know i got
excited
because now i was gonna see a [ __ ]
game
so then it's one to one and it just
keeps going and going and then i'm like
so what happens
there's no way this [ __ ] ends in a draw
and they like share the trophy
right oh we go into overtime extra time
whatever the [ __ ] they call it
so i'm watching this [ __ ] and it just
keeps going and going
and going and going and i'm like a lot
of you i took a 10-minute nap
in a soccer game for a [ __ ] world
championship whatever that was i call it
a world champ they're playing different
countries
i took a 10-minute nap felt great
woke up still one-to-one people still
singing scarves over their [ __ ] heads
and then time runs out i'm like okay
what do they do they clear the ice and
they play a second overtime
and then they start talking about a
shootout i was like oh my god i remember
this [ __ ]
from the 1994 world cup when italy was
in it
and i remember my country was all
sitting there going like
we always say you know they're the world
champions of basketball
or baseball or football or whatever and
we don't play the world
the world cup it's actually the world
playing
it's the world playing it's the final
[ __ ] thing and you solve it on these
[ __ ] penalty kicks
just doesn't seem right that it comes
down to the individual and this is where
the game
uh
i'm trying to describe the feeling i had
after this [ __ ]
so as far as i can tell and i want all
you people around the world obviously to
chime in with your
understanding as you explain this to me
in a non-condescending not littered with
f words in insult way i appreciate
from the beginning i appreciate your
professionalism and your maturities
as adults so i [ __ ]
i i sit like okay so we were watching
the world cup right and
we're like this whole world championship
where you had to beat every [ __ ]
country in the world
or half the [ __ ] world just to get in
it
and then you had to win your little
sector and then you had to go into
another [ __ ] playoff and it comes
down to you
and another team teemo atimo let's
[ __ ]
have at it and then it comes down to
penalty shots
like free throws
like the 2009 laker championship when
they called 50 000 files on the celtics
and i watched them win it from the free
throw line
the most anticlimactic championship i
ever [ __ ] saw
but anyway here we go they're still
doing it
hockey doesn't have the red line anymore
they have no touch icing
but soccer is staying with
look if you can't get it done in [ __ ]
nine hours we gotta go i guess that's
what it is it's like this game's gonna
go on forever these guys got to go
you know the chimney sweeps got to get
up early in the morning
whatever chitty chitty bang bang [ __ ]
they do over there
[Laughter]
anyway um
it comes down to these penalty kicks
and you know what [ __ ] the goalies
in this whole thing because there's like
no pressure on them
whatsoever you know what i mean it's
like
i can't say that i'll get in trouble i
want to keep my wife happy all right i
can't say that but you can figure that
one out you know one person has pressure
[Music]
um
like all they do is guess
nobody gets mad if it's supposed to go
in
all of the stress
is on the [ __ ] shooter
and you know somebody's gonna blow it
somebody's gonna hit a post somebody's
gonna hit it high
somebody's gonna have the goaltender
guess right 50 50 he guess is right
so i'm watching this [ __ ] i believe it
went italy scored
then england scored then england made
the safe
and wembley stadium is going [ __ ]
crazy
[ __ ] crazy i guess they hadn't won it
since 1966
and i was like holy [ __ ] and i was
actually kind of relieved
for the italian supporters there because
they took an ass kick and going in and
the game didn't even start right
so
they they shoot a few more and then
england [ __ ] it up
they [ __ ] hit a post or something
now it's tied again
they go a couple of more [ __ ] rounds
italy [ __ ] up again
holy [ __ ] wembley stadiums going crazy
again
then england [ __ ] up again italy scores
and then on their final [ __ ]
shot kick whatever you say they send a
[ __ ] 19 year old kid to go out there
and evidently
somebody older could have stepped up
all right i don't know why so they send
this kid there
he kicks it the goalie guess is right i
believe that's what happened
he saves it and this kid put his head in
his hands
and then pulled his shirt up over his
face and just started
crying
and then they cut to the italians going
crazy because they won
and i was just sitting there going like
oh my god that's a 19 year old kid
this is the worst [ __ ] sporting event
i've seen since i saw kenny perry losing
in front of his family so
congratulations
to italy congratulations to england
getting all the way there i mean it just
[ __ ]
you know from the tweets i was reading i
hope you guys don't [ __ ] up your city
too bad that's
i don't even understood that you didn't
[ __ ] up your own city uh it's probably
because they tax you so much
it's always something you know it's like
when vancouver connects lost to the
bruins
the stanley cup and all of a sudden they
[ __ ] start [ __ ] up their own city
you know as michael moore sits there
it's a utopia up there everybody feels
happy
um
i don't know man i ki i get it now i get
it
it's [ __ ] amazing it's an amazing
thing to have
i mean it's crazy enough over here where
it's city versus city this is country
first country so it just brings out all
kinds of [ __ ] world history
like i was literally sitting there and
watching
watching those poor fans getting this
[ __ ] kicked out of him as they walked
into the stadium
and you just see it right there it's
like this is why these people all have
to be on the same currency
they all have to be the slave to the
same [ __ ] bank because if they're not
this is what happens they're too close
together
you know they're a victim of of [ __ ]
history
you know what i mean all of those people
that were over there were over there
since
caveman times when there was no travel
those little clans of people and they
came up with their own goddamn customs
they all [ __ ] each other so everybody
sort of looks alike and it just became
teams and then
then the [ __ ] car the plane the train
and all of that [ __ ]
came about and you got all these
different tribes they're all [ __ ]
bumping up against each other it's just
too much friction over there
i mean look what the [ __ ] happened over
here and there was plenty of room
um anyway so uh i'm glad i watched it
and everything
i understand it way more uh it's a
beautiful game to watch
some idiots you know follow me on
twitter think that i actually mean all
that [ __ ] that i was saying
when did england get a new flag
i was just being a dick it was
you know what it was this is how [ __ ]
up i am is i said my money's on
england okay and then i got all these
positive remarks from [ __ ] people
from england
and i was like all right and then i felt
like i was betraying my italian friends
over here i
i just didn't the whole [ __ ] thing
didn't feel right then on the irish
people jumped i thought you were [ __ ]
irish
my god i can't [ __ ] win over here
right so
then once i heard you know it's coming
home
or whatever the slogan was
that just reminded me of the new york
yankees whenever they win and espn
literally goes in all is right
in baseball i've never understood that i
understand that expression
from a yankee fan i don't get it
from like a news media 24-hour sports
outlet like
so you think when my team or any of the
other 30 [ __ ] teams win like
something's wrong
aren't you supposed to hide that bias um
so anyway i really enjoyed it
uh i hated the ending and i felt so
[ __ ] bad
that it just for that kid man i just
feel bad for that kid and i guess people
are writing racist [ __ ] because
there's just a bunch of [ __ ] cowards
out there
that are real [ __ ] you know i don't
know
[ __ ] meatheads just [ __ ] meatheads
it's weird man you just would think that
that [ __ ] would just go away
like how many [ __ ] examples do you
need
like every [ __ ] race has their
geniuses
they're amazing people they're good
shits they're regular
people and they're [ __ ] and they're
serial killers everybody's got them
i don't understand that way hey our
[ __ ] are better than your [ __ ]
all right anyway let's get into the
advertising here for this week i haven't
even talked half of this [ __ ] here
jesus christ matt me explaining even me
explaining a soccer game took 25 minutes
did you guys take a 10-minute nap in the
middle of that um
uh so anyway um i'm still dropping
weight
still going to the gym i was 189 point
[ __ ] eight i'm now down to 185.2 i
wanted to lose three pounds of weight i
just a week
i just realized i have too many other
commitments and my metabolism is too
slow
metabolism at this [ __ ] age that two
pounds a week is all i can do
and i've learned to stop giving myself
stressful goals you know
i used to [ __ ] watch all the time
fast and loud
with richard rawlings and every the guy
would always go okay
uh i just bought a greyhound bus we're
gonna turn this thing into a [ __ ]
i don't know a dining car for a [ __ ]
ihop and and the guy wants it by uh
thursday
and i used to always just watch that
show like why the [ __ ]
do they do this i get business business
but then i understood after a while it's
like you know
it makes the show exciting
you know if you're not just into cars if
you put a clock up against it
it gives it a sense of urgency you know
them versus the clock where if it was
just a bunch of guys that knew what the
[ __ ] they were doing
building a car with enough time then
only people who enjoyed people
that are great mechanics and uh
i don't know painters and bodywork guys
i still would have watched it the
[ __ ] food network did that
these would just show people cooking it
was great then all of a sudden it's just
like
we we gotta we gotta add stress so
people will watch here's some yogurt
make a poached egg how do i do that i
don't know you got three minutes
[ __ ] and they just start running around
the kitchen
it's really [ __ ] stupid so anyway
i am uh i'm down to one 185.2 so i'm
just gonna do two pounds a week and
rather than being down to my
all the way down where i wanted to be by
the beginning of september it might take
me to mid-october but that's all right
as long
as i'm moving in the right direction uh
it's been great to get back to the gym
and whatnot and um
yeah that's been uh it's been a good
thing you know i don't know
we went out on um we went out on
uh saturday night and we
i had a little stuff to eat i shouldn't
have [ __ ] ate but i've been good
all week but then and then me and my
wife went to this place
i got the hiccups now and watch the
conor mcgregor vs dustin uh
poirier fight um
which it sucked the way it ended um
i was rooting for conor mcgregor because
i really wanted uh i hate when a oh what
an older
he's only 32 but when an older great
fighter loses
i just hate that thing where all of
these people on twitter
who haven't had a fight since like
[ __ ] junior high like me all of a
sudden
you get your [ __ ] ass kick they start
talking [ __ ] to somebody like that
i just hate that or they you know
i always just feel like you know certain
people so even like certain announcers
you know they enjoy
when the champ gets knocked off his
throne
because i think this is a lot of people
that just can't handle
like how badass like i mean that's the
most badass thing ever man or woman you
just
walk into a [ __ ] arena
to fight and you come out victorious i
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody in the
crowd did
nobody is cooler than that you know you
got to go to like somebody who's like a
war hero
um to beat that so um
you know i don't know
that was probably wasn't woke i probably
should have said something about women
there i don't know um anyway
so i was rooting for conor mcgregor plus
i'm an old guy you know
so i'm going to see the older guy win i
like dustin poirier and i figured this
kid's got his whole career ahead of him
and then i realized oh [ __ ] he's 32 also
it's kind of weird so
i don't know so then i had a bet with my
wife
do i have just tell you right now if you
want a [ __ ] sports system
i used to be able to call games before i
had kids i could call games i just can't
watch enough now and i can't pick a
i haven't i haven't picked a [ __ ] one
like the mush
in uh bronx tale
i haven't picked a [ __ ] winner i
don't i don't know when
um just right and left so i bet conor
mcgregor
she bet dustin poirier and uh my wife's
hilarious when she watches
the uh ufc she is out uh when it starts
getting exciting she gets out of her
seat
and is [ __ ] walking around the room
screaming at the tv
like she [ __ ]
loses it she's like knees knees elbows
yes
yes she just [ __ ]
she [ __ ] goes crazy
um so we were in a public place and she
was doing that people just like
laughing you know it's just funny to see
a woman do that if i do it i'm just a
loud-mouthed [ __ ] but she does it's
just like jesus christ
sleep with one eye open there freckles
um
so anyway uh just sucked away the fight
end that had to end on like
injury i was kind of hoping
uh i wanted to see that second round to
see what would have happened
everybody seems to like know what was
going to happen or whatever but
you know oh connor was coming back oh
you know dustin would have knocked him
out it's like yeah
we don't know now so uh
i actually felt bad for connor when he
was sitting there i know he's yelling
all kinds of [ __ ] up [ __ ] at dustin
but it was just like
you know i don't know what that's like
to be just like how
i can be a comedian until i [ __ ] keel
over where these guys have like a
a window and it must feel as great
to them to do what they do as it does
for what i do
and i can't imagine if my whole [ __ ]
stand-up career was over 32 now what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do
so i feel he was a little bit in that
head plus plus i think he was still
trying to sell
you know sell like the next fight but
jesus christ
your wife is in my dms jesus
and dustin said yeah he was grabbing my
gloves he's a dirt bag
i mean that's the first time i felt like
i saw like uh
because they usually say all kinds of
crazy [ __ ]
and then afterwards they're so nice
that's the only time
i can really remember where it sounded
like pre-fight hype now either the two
of them are the greatest
you know promoters ever but um
i like people going he went too far you
don't say things about his wife it's
[ __ ] talking about they say all kinds
of crazy or like you know he said he was
going to murder me
it's like well you didn't say he was
going to eat your children
he didn't say he was going to [ __ ] you
until you love me you know there's a lot
much crazier [ __ ] has been said than
that
um he's selling the fight he's selling
the fight and he's conor mcgregor and if
you fight him you make up
all right my [ __ ] recorder crapped
out on me thought i had a charge what
the hell was i talking about i had to
sit here and watch [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] i was
watching grizzly bears
murdering other animals those dumb [ __ ]
i didn't what i was talking about dude
how come bears this can be
you guys like what the [ __ ] are we
talking about now sorry like a half hour
went by in my life
um i just don't understand why
bears don't know how to kill something
quickly and efficiently
they're [ __ ] morons
just [ __ ] just clamp down they clamp
down on the on the back of the neck
just keep yanking yanking yanking
[ __ ]
deer everything's screaming in agony
it's like just [ __ ] kill the thing
start eating before it's dead what the
[ __ ] is wrong i don't know i used to
really
like bears i still like bears i i think
you know must be an arrogant human
statement like i think they they should
live
[Laughter]
i heard they're making a comeback in
tennessee you know which is [ __ ]
amazing
considering the way everybody's packing
out in that [ __ ] state if i was a
bear i'd go to nashville a lot of
liberals just moved out there they could
be some [ __ ] fast food if you know
what i mean
i'm just not into guns i just think we
should all what the [ __ ] is that
whatever the [ __ ] noise the thing
makes oh my god
you must go into shock
i don't know leonardo dicaprio didn't
seem like he went into shock when that
thing was biting [ __ ] meat out of his
back my god
i know it was a movie but you know what
i mean it was based on a wasn't it based
on something true
i don't know anyways i uh i think
my [ __ ] toe is coming back i was
chasing my daughter this morning that's
what i do i
chase my kids they love it and then they
turn around they want to chase me so my
daughter's getting bigger she's getting
faster so i used to be able to turn the
corner before she saw me i could die
behind the couch
and she wouldn't see me and she'd do
another lap around and then i'd jump out
and i scare her
so i went to do the move and she saw me
and she caught me so this time i came
running around
and i'm looping around and then i went
to make a left
and there was some stairs you know you
take one step down into this next room
and i was wearing slippers and as i was
approaching the stairs i turned back to
see if she was gonna see me
and i basically skied down these stairs
and [ __ ]
my left foot hit first on the big toe
uh really the three toes the big toe and
the two back up dancers to the big toe
the next the next two right
and [ __ ] uh yeah i was just down
and it was like it hurt so bad it took
like a minute
before it it just felt like i just
stubbed
three toes really bad which is the worst
so i was laying down
and um you know my wife didn't think i
was hurt that bad
she's just looking at me like oh great
now i have to watch both the kids
because you're running and i told you
not to run
um and then you know once my toe i think
and once my toe turned purple she
finally was like oh [ __ ] you really
[ __ ] yourself up it's like well i i
said i did
you know it's amazing if my wife jesus i
just looked at it for the first time
wow i love you
do you think you broke it do you think
you broke your toe what am i gonna get a
toe cast
i think i don't i don't know i hope not
oh why am i such a dick they're just
trying to help me up
what are you gonna do what is going on
here does this thing shut off again no
it didn't all right let's get through
this here i don't know how much time i
did i did like a half hour i think let's
do another half hour i think i should be
good
before this thing shuts off all right
let's do a couple of reads here
all right candid everybody there's a
specialist for just about everything
right
or at least somebody thinks they are uh
when my car breaks down i go to a
mechanic
when there's a problem with my shower i
call a plumber both of those statements
are true
i stand by that i stand by that copy
so when you want to get your uneven
crooked teeth fixed
england uh you see an
orthodontist this specialist dude you
can't tell me you guys aren't doing
invisalign
invisalign over in england you got to do
it you got to [ __ ] do it jesus christ
i think you you you could jump your
number by four
it used to be a five now you're a nine
uh and that's what sets candid the
invisible
comfortable and removable aligners above
the rest
while poorly reviewed or insanely priced
clear aligner companies
use general dentists candid only works
with orthodontists the specialists
this is all they do is fix your [ __ ]
smile
with candid the same orthodontist who
created your plan
is with you from start to finish so you
never have to wonder
how you're doing your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely
by a licensed orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth movement
you can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you
or do everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home the average
candid treatment is just six months
you'll start seeing results way before
then
um and it costs less than traditional
braces
and with your aligner treatment you'll
get candids teeth whitening for free
look at that you straighten them out you
whiten them up and next thing you know
everybody thinks you're a
game show host candid can help you get
the straighter brighter smile you've
always wanted right now
you can save 75 dollars on your candid
starter kit when you
get started from home or you can book an
appointment at a candid studio near you
today
go to candid co dot com slash bar and
use the code bur
burr that's candid co.com code bur
take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75
dollars on your starter kit candid
charlie oscar
candidco.com code burr
oh look who it is everybody it's
all zip
code that pause was so long a grizzly
bear could almost kill something
uh recent data shows that out of all the
female-owned businesses it is estimated
that one in three
is owned by a mom look at that
what are they bitching about one in
three
businesses is owned by a mom and she
gets all the dad's money i mean what the
that's like winning both showcases uh
ever wonder how these amazing moms and
dads find time to hire that for their
businesses while juggling their families
with zip
and right now you can try it for free
only at zip
dot com slash burr ceo and founder talia
goldstein is one such mompreneur
besides being a mother of two her
personalized matchmaking company
three-day rule
is constantly growing and she needs to
hire several matchmakers a month
so she uses zip recruiter zip
ricardo's powerful technology helps her
find the people with the right
experience and
actively invites them to apply but talia
is not the only employer who loves zip
four to five employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first
first day and right now you can try
ziprecruiter for free
at this web address ziprecruiter.com
this special offer is only good at
ziprecruiter.com
the smartest way to hire all right
there we go so there's your advertising
is my recorder still on ah we are in
business we are in business
all right business dreams uh dear billy
one
two i don't see it ever happening well
jesus there's a way to [ __ ] start a
dream
i don't see it ever happening but i
always dreamed about what it would be
like
to own a small bait and tackle shop on a
lake
coffee and paper at 5 00 a.m people
coming in
asking how they're biting sounds perfect
what's your dream business
you'll probably never own well first of
all let's go back
to your little dream
i always dreamed about what it's like
throwing small bait and tackle shop
on a lake coffee and the paper at 5 a.m
is that you or you would sell that too
people coming in asking how they're
biting you know what's cool about that
is like you'd be done working by like no
one comes in to buy bait at like noon
right
but he gotta hang around after they
didn't get [ __ ]
you know i feel like fishermen and
golfers are the same thing
they're always blaming their equipment
[Music]
you can just say i'll tell you get this
reel over here man they'll be jumping
into your [ __ ] boat
are you serious i'm serious or that a
[ __ ] fat woman flying the organ in a
[ __ ] bastard
um people coming in asking how they're
biting sounds perfect
yeah i like that man i like the sound of
a quiet life
i will be honest with you um
you know i always think you know if i
had kids earlier
you know well they'd be all [ __ ] up
because i was pretty [ __ ] up back then
so i had kids when i was supposed to
have but if i had them earlier
they'd be getting out of the house
they'd be out of the house by now i'm
53.
uh
i could really you know
i would be working out like how the [ __ ]
i was gonna get out of this business
or maybe it's just you're just always
tired when you have kids i don't know
what it is
you just get they just dad dad daddy dad
dad dad
it's like you know um
i don't know what it is but uh that
quiet life okay what's the your dream
business
you'll probably never own
oh well [ __ ]
me and paul verzi uh talk about owning a
cigar bar
like buying like a strip mall and just
having like
you know like a you have to
have like a [ __ ] a cigar bar
a pizza place and then like a barber
shop
go down there you get something to eat
you get your hair cut you [ __ ] you
have a cigar or whatever
i don't know i kind of looked into like
owning a cigar bar and like it gets
real really quickly and it's not even
the
uh the cost
of like buying a building or renting a
place
and then furnishing it with all of the
[ __ ] it's it's
the cigars and like how that works like
i heard if you if you get in business
with
davidoff you have to take on all of
their cigars
so then i'm just like well what does
that mean you know what i mean so
so i guess what you're saying is like
that thing that you probably wouldn't
make any money off of
but you you would just enjoy being
around that um
yeah i think like a cigar bar
i really love those places i like how
quiet they are
and i like when they get loud it's only
because something funny is happening or
so they're talking about
sports it's just a uh
you know it's a tremendous tremendous
place um
see was it anything else i think back in
the day when i was a kid i wanted to own
like a
like a sporting goods store
because i just love sports so much i
just thought it'd be cool to be [ __ ]
have a store and there's a bunch of
you know bats balls gloves hockey
equipment all of that [ __ ] workout stuff
i still love the big five out here i
love going in there i love the smell
of a sporting goods store they always
smell like rubber
i don't know what it what that is it
used to be like the floor mats or
whatever you just walk in
some reason i just heard the sound you
like jingling of the bell
and you came in um by the way speaking
of the amount of [ __ ] that is electric
that didn't need to be electric now that
like cities are becoming like 130
degrees
and people are still questioning whether
you know we're having an effect on all
of this
um but i'm positive that we're going to
figure it out because if i don't i'll
have my head in the oven
um which would actually be good for the
environment
um which is an old dug stand open
killing yourself is the greenest thing
you could ever do
i [ __ ] love that joke um
anyway um
yeah i don't know i think it at my age i
actually think that uh
if you could just help out other people
in a quiet way you could just do it in a
quiet way
and not be [ __ ] parading around like
look what i'm doing
because that always ruins it you know
what i mean
i wish people that got money would then
help people out
who didn't have money that deserved it
rather than you know
some money grubbing [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
um maybe there's a business
you could start a [ __ ] business where
you vetted people
for people who had money that wanted to
help out people but didn't have the
[ __ ] time
to figure out if this person was a dirt
bag
who actually is just lazy and doesn't
want to [ __ ] work as opposed to
somebody
who's working their ass off and you know
god knows what happened
beyond the pandemic that got him into a
situation
something like that i don't know one of
those two things
um things i should have said i'll tell
you jobs i used to want to have
like i i always wanted to drive a tow
truck
be that guy in the back of a uh the
latter
fire engine you know that steers all the
way in the back
um be a milkman
drive one of those big [ __ ] trucks i
wanted to be a truck driver
um garbage man
mailman all the jobs i saw
or people you got some sort of a car and
it just or a truck and it just [ __ ]
looked fun
and then i did some of those jobs like
this [ __ ] job sucks
like construction i tried doing that one
summer oh my god
i just was not i wasn't good at it and
then it's just like holy [ __ ]
i don't think i ever ate so much i would
bring like [ __ ] three sandwiches
and i was still dropping weight did i
just start
a new fad diet the construction diet you
know construction workers are
great they're really not in great shape
but a lot of them are
you know i did three sets of carrying
two by fours
all right things i should have said
number one hey billy button bulges oh
i love fat shaming keep it coming um i
was at my best friend's wedding when my
boss made a comment about me
oh wow you got a little you got a little
drunk
you got a little drunk uh quick
background my best friend's
older brother had a buddy whose dad used
to run a pizza shop
out here in the afc east
okay all right wait a minute i already
got lost because that i don't know what
the [ __ ] i just started thinking about
i think i was still thinking about
businesses all right was that a best
friend's wedding when my old boss
old boss ah made a comment about you oh
quick background my best friend's older
brother had a buddy
whose dad used to run a pizza shop out
here in the afc east
they have since sold the business so we
are not trashing them in any way
most of the people working at the pizza
shop were friends from school
oh she's gonna say or he's gonna say
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about this pizza
parlor
most of the people working the pizza
shop were friends from school this was
just a high school job that we all took
to make some extra cash
anyway i was a back room guy since i was
only 16 with no car yet so i could wash
clean and prep the pizza cut
cut the tomatoes [ __ ] like that
obviously at 16 i knew my calling wasn't
going to be a pizza boy my whole life
fast forward to the wedding the old
owner of the pizza shop
oh i assumed that the boss was a guy
oh so far look at this look at her being
[ __ ] a little uh
harriet weinstein here um
i went over to say hi talk talk about
the old pizza shop since
it sold by the time we were at the
wedding the owner had a few
jack and cokes and in front of the whole
table
put his arm around me and say oh it is a
guy
said i'm not gonna lie buddy you were my
worst employee by far
the whole table laughed at the comment
side note i was the best man at the
wedding so the table was filled with the
groom's family and friends
i never got in trouble at the pizza shop
but my two day
there i broke the tomato but my second
day there huh
my second day there i broke the tomato
slicer by mistake
i forced a bigger one through and it
just jammed after that
i assumed maybe that's why he said it i
still don't know why he said it he might
have just been breaking your balls
i'm 33 now
and that it happened four years ago and
out of respect i just brushed off the
comment at the time
however i wish i had said something
quick-witted like well i guess you
dropped the ball
when you hired me or something like that
uh
nah nah yeah whatever he's just breaking
your balls
it's just guy [ __ ] right i gotta tell
you you were my worst employee by far
and he should have been like
yeah well i gotta tell you something man
that was the worst pizza i ever had so
you hired the right guy am i right
fellas huh
who's getting that dick wet tonight all
right dumb [ __ ] you say at a wedding
sorry being extra gross here uh anyway i
got a
a wife a great wife and a son who's
eight months and a daughter
who's gonna be four in november look at
you congratulations i'm a banker [ __ ] so
i definitely progressed from the pizza
shop days
i got nothing to complain about but i
think uh
about this a lot and i see him from time
to time
and now i introduce myself as employer
of the month
um when i see him well that's good so
you rolled with it
hope to see you soon go bills oh bills
the new kings of the afc east
with josh allen exciting things going on
in buffalo
out there in uh well [ __ ] war
memorial stadium whatever you guys play
um all right number two
two two two hey billy cue ball
uh back when i was a senior in high
school
in 2017 i was taking a class that was
for seniors
who were preparing to go off to college
on this particular day we were
talking about how we go about things
with roommates
i guess college roommates my teacher
brought up this situation about if you
walked in on your roommate having sex
and she asked what would we do
or uh or say and i just
abruptly yelled tag me in
then a girl replied with who would want
to sleep with you
oh jesus he says oh man so you got you
got it
you must have gotta laugh
oh you should have been like you if i
had enough money you dumb [ __ ]
but you never think to say that anyway i
have thought about that
since the day it happened i wish i told
the dumb [ __ ] to go [ __ ] herself i
still think about things i should have
said
what do you think i should have said you
should have laughed because you know
something
she listened to that story and put her
you listen to the story
and you put yourself into it right hey
tag me in
so then she put herself into it and
she's the woman getting banged by this
guy and some guy walks in and said i got
next
so that's what she just gotta sometimes
you just gotta understand where people
were coming from
it's better that you didn't say anything
um and who knows you're only four years
out of
you know high school you might bang this
broad someday
cause the next time i'd see her i'd be a
sweetheart
you know tell her she looks good even if
she doesn't you know
take it and go see one of those uh who's
that bumbling english guy there he does
the romantic comedy he's take it to one
of those and see what happens
uh i think he did the right thing you
you left out the part when you said tag
me in like you didn't get a [ __ ] big
laugh
i think it was so funny she got into her
feelings there so i
i think i think that was a victory you
know what i mean
i think you scored the game-winning goal
and then uh who was that guy who
cross-checked that guy after he scored
the goal in the playoff
uh dale hunter she kind of dale hunted
you with the who would want to sleep
with you
checked you into the boards all right
things i should not have said
hey red velvet bill
i don't even know what that means but
that just sounds creepy
um where am i before my battery runs out
okay i got like eight minutes left here
okay here we go
um when i was in the ninth grade i had a
health teacher
who was an [ __ ] he was mainly a track
coach so he didn't give a [ __ ] about his
classes and would talk down to anybody
who wasn't in track
oh jesus that was great description i
already hate this guy one day i had to
stay after school and make up for an
assignment i failed because it was a
group project and the partner didn't
care
or do their work i tried to explain it
to him but he said
sounds like uh sounds like that's a
personal problem
so i just stared at him until he went
what and i just said
you're a dick nice
he proceeded to give a 50 on every
assignment for the rest of the year and
failed me
i didn't give a [ __ ] about having to
retake a class but my mom wouldn't
help get me a license for all of high
school for failing a class so i had to
wait until i was 19 to get one
wow old school parenting there should
have kept my mouth shut
and done his assignment so i wouldn't
have to ask for so many rides thanks
for everything you're doing go [ __ ]
yourself no you know something [ __ ] that
guy
he's a dick and he didn't give a [ __ ] he
had a really important job teaching
people so he is a dick and you told him
that's good you sp
you said what you felt you got your
license now gives a [ __ ] you got a great
story good for you
you stand by that one all right number
two
hey billy butter cheeks
[ __ ] guns i just want to get this off
my chest
a few years ago i was working in arizona
and the company provided me and my
two roommates with an apartment one
roommate was a dude
who i got along with um the other was an
insufferable lady who never
shut up and thought she was way funnier
than she actually was well that's fun to
be around
needless to say she annoyed the [ __ ] out
of me
oh boy in this nice ass apartment my
room happened to have a balcony
connected to it
it was the sole property of my room you
could not
get to it except by walking through my
room one night i had a few friends over
and we went to the balcony to have a few
drinks and a smoke
all of a sudden this [ __ ] appears on my
balcony and says
oh this is where you all are to clarify
she walked through my room i'm already
fuming wow this is a really nice balcony
she said and here's the thing
i shouldn't have said [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that you should go hard here
you should go hard here he says here's
the thing i shouldn't have said he said
uh she says wow this is a really nice
balcony so i say yes it is
and it's connected to my room so in the
future don't come here unless you're
invited
well dude i mean that's maybe because
you said it in front of all those people
i think i think it was [ __ ] great
all my friends looked at me like i was
the reincarnation of hitler
it was so silent i could hear them
thinking did i just hear this
[ __ ] right
well because they didn't know the
backstory all she said was [ __ ] you too
well [ __ ] her man
loudmouth [ __ ] don't ever walk through
your bedroom
look i don't even know these people but
the way you guys described them i just
side with you guys
all right and walked away i spent an
hour apologizing the apartment was tense
for the rest of the job
ah you apologized
that's the part you shouldn't have said
no so this is where you are don't
[ __ ] walk tomorrow look you shouldn't
have said it in front of me you should
have taken her side said listen
do me a favor i you know i don't walk
into your room please don't walk into my
room
oh my god oh my god that reminds me of
one time a long time ago this promoter
would just walk into the green room
i did a run of dates and just go hello
hello
or just go knock knock and then we'll
just walk in and start talking
it's like who raised you who the [ __ ]
raised you
that's that's like that's not how you
enter a room
if people are talking am i crazy oh my
god that drove me up the
[ __ ] wall
hello hello knack knack oh my god
and i didn't say anything because i i
didn't i knew i was too angry a person
back then now i could have just solved
it after one night
can you do me a favor um rather than
saying knock knock or just yelling hello
hello
from down the hall i would appreciate it
that if i'm in mid conversation
with the other comedian you would
politely knock
and wait till we said come in
ah that just felt good saying that you
know sometimes you just you know the
other person doesn't know
so that one person i just was talking
about they weren't an [ __ ] i just
didn't know how to [ __ ] communicate
and see people when you take
responsibility
ladies listen to this when you take
when you take responsibility for your
actions you can then try to find a
solution
um i don't know but this isn't this
isn't a big
time for that is it it doesn't seem oh
bill quit your [ __ ] whining
you're doing great you're on the road
you're selling tickets
you're going up there wearing a little
silk shirt you know to cover your
blubber
um people don't know that you wear a
silk shirt it hides like 30 pounds
joking it actually doesn't i don't even
know if it does i don't know any silk
shirts i just wanted to put that [ __ ]
rumor out there so people would start
doing it
what it really does is attract attention
to the you know the part of the body
you're trying to hide
no billy big shirt for another couple of
weeks
old billy hooded sweatshirt hey bill
it's july at
i don't want to talk about it next
question
did anybody see that thing that guy did
on one of the instagrams of tick tock
where he imitated a coach after losing
like a big playoff game but he was just
acting like a dad
you know like what happened out there
he's just going like well you know we uh
just i just felt like we were behind at
the beginning of the day you know crying
on the wall
and something like that the guy does it
[ __ ] perfectly
it's amazing amazing piece of comedy um
all right that's it that's the podcast
everybody once again congratulations to
italy
um england sorry you got that close man
it [ __ ] sucks but uh go easy on that
kid man it's a 19 year old kid he's got
his whole life ahead of him
all right don't take out your [ __ ]
childhood
on this kid and don't [ __ ] say a
bunch of ignorant [ __ ]
because you were raised by ignorant
people break the [ __ ] cycle
okay be a grinch grow a [ __ ] heart
you know bring the christmas tree back
don't be a [ __ ] all right that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thursday